talk about uh influences coming up in
bands and [__] like what were some of
your band influences like like give me
your like three or four greatest bands
of all time bands okay um let's go bands
first yeah of all time I see so as far
as like in influence goes I'd have to
say like so there's a band called uh
acceptance when I was like in like sixth
grade uh first band I ever like really
got into acceptance like changed my life
I remember playing like you remember
like NFL Street 2 when that came out
like NFL Street was that the one with
Ricky Williams on the cover BR they had
they had like exhibit was in it uh but
everybody it was dude it was all the
street games are so fire so sick man
they so sick I mean the uh the I I
recently played sorry to get off track
here but I recently played the NBA
streets and the the old school one yeah
the camera it's like side angle so you
kind of don't have really depth
perception you're just like kind of
going right by the goal it doesn't hold
up as well as you remember no but NBA
Street NFL Street and the what was the
skate games the uh skate the skate that
was all my [__] yeah we got to bring all
that [__] the uh the the oh man and the
uh de Jam vendettas bro come on bro who
would you be during like dude U Man red
man every time red man was my hero dude
well how high is like one of my favorite
movies of all time with him and meth
yeah man it's like one of the best
movies of all time it's so funny like
that that game existed I had that game
and then there was this wuang game on
Playstation it was a fighting game where
you could pick like all nine members of
wuang and then you'd fight like evil
monks and [__] that's so sick but yeah
Vendetta was that [__] for
sure well but anyway fans so there was
there was a song on to uh on on uh on
NFL Street too and it was this song
called in to far by acceptance and I was
like I just fell in love with it and I
went and found this album Phantoms and
it just like changed my life it's one of
the first ones I ever listened to I like
God I want this is like I was all they
were all over my MySpace like everything
like all all songs all their whole that
whole album is all over my MySpace so I
like acceptance is up there for me um
circus survive man Anthony Green one of
the greatest of all times I think as far
as a van goes I was so I was so invested
in Circus survive still am man I mean
he's he's in LS Dunes now just he's just
one of the greatest I think um chotos
man also all 2007 like Warp Tour you
know just two chotos was incredible man
I uh warp was in ER God it was so that
was one of the first shows I ever went
to man and uh I mean I'll have to I
obviously have to throw Van Halen in
there too as bands go cuz come on uh uh
Lincoln Park man on Chester man yeah
come on man Nota just came out on stage
at um some radio show I was like oh [__]
I think he came on stage with somebody
he they they've changed my life man I
got those first two albums man were like
my childhood dude Hybrid Theory is one
of the first ones I got that uh I got my
when my first like Christmas where I got
um got CDs and you remember when they
used to be wrapped and you just knew
your parents got you those yeah cuz it
was a shape of a c yeah it was dude but
I had gotten I had gotten Hybrid Theory
um U no pads no helmets just balls but
Simple Plan and uh there was there was
like a three CD set of switch foot it
was like Legend of chin and I forget the
other two uh Records on it but it's like
three CDs all the you knew you were
getting CDs for Christmas and DVDs or
games you'd be like is this a movie or
game yeah yeah that that was that was
the catchy F yeah did you get a DVD or
or video game I hope it's a game I hope
it's not a [__] movie I don't I don't
want to I don't want to copy of Click
you know what I mean I don't need clerks
I'm fine I you know no that's dope man
yeah know Lincoln Park I got to see them
uh I I went as a kid to the Hybrid
Theory tour a so jealous and they had a
this there's this rapper named MC
Supernatural I don't know if you ever
heard of him but supernat is like the
freestyle God yeah right so at the time
he would do this [__] where he would I
would see him on these like smaller
hip-hop shows with like dilated people's
of Jurassic 5 and [__] um and he would
do this thing where he would spin around
and come as like and impersonate another
rapper so he'd like spin around and be
rapping like exhibit and then he'd spin
around he'd be rapping sick and he's the
first person I ever saw like take
someone's ID from the crowd and wrap
their name and their birthplace and so
they had him open the um Lincoln Park
tour and it was so C crazy but cuz I
never seen somebody combine like
hardcore real hip-hop [__] and like rock
[__] in that way and without it being
corny yeah they they were dude cuz there
were some corny the the rap rock era it
got corny it got a little corny you know
and I think a lot of that has to do with
Joe Han too man because he that just did
Lincoln Park always had that that DJ you
know they had the DJ and they had like
and they had the roots too like styles
of beond and [__] yeah exactly they
they're just real real hip-hop fans I
think entirely you know and I think like
I I got a chance to work with them a
couple times and just kind of go over to
mics and and experiment with them and
play and it was so cool cuz I've never
seen I've never seen actually like Joe
still he like still has like so when
they're sampling stuff it's not like
they're going to splice like everyone
else he everyone's doing he's really
he's really pulling out records and and
finding moments in there and sampling
them real time still as they're like
writing and I'm like dude it was so neat
to see cuz I've never seen that just
somebody sample live into recording how
they do it as opposed to like on website
download an MP3 and put it it's so easy
for us now which thank God I would I
like that about it I would be [__]
lost if it was up to me you like man if
I got to go sit in this it's great just
go like high hat 130bpm and
just oh that one you know it's that's so
sick to do that now I'm like I wouldn't
change it for the world but it was cool
to see that like he's still he's still
dedicated to you know like and do DJ
just like really doing like when people
are really using records still it's so
[__] it's got to be cool like for you
like have you realized that you cuz you
know I always say we grow up having a
dream and then when we accomplish
accomplish the dream like if somebody
were to tell probably you 10 years ago
that you'd have a million views on
YouTube you'd be like oh [__] [__]
right we're on but like I feel like when
we hit those dreams like we don't even
like take time to like really appreciate
it it's always about what's next yeah I
try I try to I try to like I'm trying to
get to that point but you know you're so
in it that you like I'm sit in a room
with Mike shenoda and like the Lincoln
Park guys I'm like freaking out oh man
yeah that was definitely one of those
times where we we we're talking about
things and I was just like look guys
like I'm stoked that we're friends but
just don't ever forget that I'm going to
be more of a fan than I'll ever be your
friend like I I love you so much you
know like I'm I'm just here to like soak
in sponge in all the little stories like
tell me [__] everything I know
everything you know cuz they're and they
it's just like man also recording vocals
with Mike Shoto is like such a uh he's
such a he's such a [__] genius when
it comes to that because he'll he'll do
this thing to which I'm like such a
chameleon because I grew up on such
different type of music so if we're
doing something Rock I just instantly
kind of find myself gearing my voice
towards this particular sound or like if
we're doing like some mot toown I kind
of gear my voice towards like and I kind
of play a character a lot you know and
he kind of broke me down and was like
okay okay okay says try this take again
and we could be the most [__]
heaviest part of the song and he's like
but don't give me such rock and roll
Teddy give me like give me m give me
like yeah try that one out see what that
character says like okay is there in
between of those two that you can kind
of do okay so why don't you give me like
your like why don't you give you more
like Indy Rock Voice or why don't you
give me more this kind of voice try some
[__] weird give me musical theater T
right here like you're or offer just
give me some offro you know and he's and
we'll just he'll kind of like carve it
I'll just like damn I never thought
those things would go together you know
because my brain just goes like like you
know and I don't I don't think to trade
change my voice to not fit what it is
you have the ability to do so much like
if you dropped the country album
tomorrow nobody would think tce like
that's that's what I that's what I like
if you did a a full R&B
album that's the plan man I hope to I
hope to be able to just kind of I always
I always wanted to say that like uh I
will forever be um I I could be second
best at anything for sure and and that's
enough like I I can cuz you couldn't put
this person in a you couldn't you know
like Chris Brown couldn't put out a
country record I mean he could I'm sure
he crush it but he does his thing you
know but people would be like really
George Straight wouldn't put out a you
know like you couldn't put him in RB
record I mean you could I'm sure you
could but they would do their thing you
know and so I always like gave myself
this like I I will be second best at
every one of these things don't you
worry I think I can I can guarantee you
I'll be second best at all of them